you spent $800 on a stripper I know that
was a little bit of your money and the
tax refund money yes Wow
what are you doing man it's that I I
know I know trust me it was a long walk
to the train that night did you realize
what an idiot you had been like yeah fry
like two seconds after I left you don't
have that kind of money I know I know
she was just she got me at a very
vulnerable moment in my drunkenness and
what does she say to get the money out
of you give me your money
uh you were there's a champagne room you
were the kid who stopped drinking you
don't even drink and then you're
drinking and blowing eight hundred bucks
I know you can only take out from the
ATM it scores 100 bucks at a clip right
and I think they charge you to 995 every
time you take it outside on top of the
800 JD upset me
i I'm fine I learned I know not to spend
that kind of money when you don't have
that kind of money before you spent the
trip the problem is you go and you get
drunk and then you get taken advantage
of what have you learned I learned
tonight get so crazy and know my limits
and be responsible when JD says he
learned I'm afraid what he learned this
for the right amount of money a chick
will touch him that's what I think
you're a nerd you're supposed to be
spending that kind of money on Star Wars
junk man on checks is it true that every
time you guys go to scores you go as a
group and all the guys you go with
always tell you don't go in the
champagne room it's a lot of money you
can't afford it and every time you do it
we warned him that night not to do it
and he just he was so drunk he just
refused to listen that was the drunkest
I've ever been that's not true dude I've
seen you fall on the floor
we went from I'm never gonna drink in my
life because I'm against drinking too
like now you're as shit-faced drunk this
is like rare occasions so I every time
every time he's there but I don't
when am i there though liquid car
wouldn't mind every time you're there
when am i there though I don't know okay
and everyday how about your tax return
the last time you lost your tax return
well don't know that was this no no no
no no no you did this before he's done
this before yes yes yes you ought to see
his face when he came out of that room
please it was like somebody somebody put
a gun to his head he was a white I can't
believe this credit card debt and
drinking this pattern is stopping I am
stopping this would you tell me every
time you come there all right listen get
out of here go hey show me yourself
somewhere else
[Laughter]